Lock em to this 15-minute game against
Bob Alderson no there is no explanation
in there both this name maybe there is
some this is some character from a book
or something I again turn out to be
completely oblivious you gave update
okay then in Palo variation of the
caricom let's see knight c6 is the maybe
most interesting way to play but black
can also play e6 or g6 okay I should g5
and here as black i play this funky move
94 but don't get that too often played
against you it's not a very well known
line okay well hissy six move is also
perfectly well it what I'm trying to do
is play in a way that and maybe I'm able
to capture on c4 in one move if he takes
so I don't want to really play Bishop d3
on something like that I try to make
useful moves and see what black will do
I wonder if b6 is now possible or if the
loose knight on c6 is a problem yeah I
think see if I should be quite good
after b6
we are not quite sure what black should
do here b6 cd5 well see if I've ed5 is
just a good structure for white p6s
pointless and also see if I've 95 night
XD 5 and then push a g5 count lots of
staying yeah he's taking us time not
quite sure maybe well what what what
could like do I mean besides be 694
could be a move trying to exchange a bit
also maybe after the trade of trade of
Bishops you might have the e7 square for
your queen which is often a problem in
this kind of structures that also often
arise from the Queens gambit you
sometimes have a problem with your queen
on d8 it does not really have a good
square on the DNC far very often rooks
are coming and good square would be e
seven really but there is just always
this bishop so it's also a reason why
some lines let's say like the the lusca
variation of the Queens gambit it's
always some has very solid foundations
94 Bishop e7 Queenie 7 it just gives a
very nice square for the Queen and 294
here says certainly a possibility he's
taking really lots of time quite quite a
lot
a move that I maybe would consider here
to move a six trying to pass quite well
what are you doing are you going to move
your f1 bishop at some point or not and
let's say six Bishop b3 and then I'd
take on c4 Bishop Taylor and b5 to get
the queenside fully developed it could
be could be an option on a six I can
also consider c5 though c5 and be
thought this would be probably a good
reply to specifically a six as it has
made it more difficult to attack this
advanced pawn chain if the eponymous but
ok I don't know what he is going to do a
six is not a very obvious smooth ok he
decided to just take it and then I
really now when I actually have managed
to take see form in in one go no b6 hmm
really
let's consider d5 now or after castleton
it looks a bit early without castling
really
yeah I think I cannot manage without
having castled you know d5 there is
Knight a5 probably rendering the whole
procedure useless so I rather retreat
this yeah and now it gets interesting I
can on the right circumstance play d5
opening up the center to my advantage I
can play a standard iqp position with
Queen let's say to d3 and bishop to be
one setting up this this battery against
h7 now he's telling me hi seem possible
that I know the guy because he's got no
name in down and it's a who had served
quite interesting account it's an older
account can put this in it's an order
account like 2007 or something but it's
it's very much focused on playing longer
time control only a couple of blitz
games which are maybe a widow and then
standard 15 minute around interesting
it's not a bad thing to do playing those
rapid games a term is suddenly um guys
it has a bit more um of pure chess value
then then blitz chess but you need to
know let's say what you're looking for
blitz games can also be a quite good um
training tool and you simply you get
more games plate which is so simply very
helpful if you want to practice an
opening for example it's some certainly
helpful to play it they didn't like it
it's a 10-5 minute games instead
of just three longer games okay he went
to d5 hmm going for trades
I don't want to take on v7 relieved this
would certainly help Black Knight c7
locating d5 firmly but of course he just
threatens to to take on g5 I wonder if I
should play a move like H form or is
this totally ridiculous I don't think so
let's let's try that tribe play it a bit
more interestingly maybe just age 60
and I don't only have a good place to
retreat ok now that look ok I was
thinking I wanted to go Knight to e5 but
i just realized that you can play night
f5 after that which is very very am
solid ok get the bishop here
mm yeah somehow this 95 move was really
helpful for black the straighter is not
really something that helps me much an
important point is that at any place
blacken or just do Knight to f6 and on
f6 it covers the h7 square the meeting
square after Queen d3 and well the
knight on f6 is just very stable
yea tall black black is probably doing
okay here use exchanged a bit this
bishop and he has good stability anthem
and blocking out there of them ice lady
porn that's quite a Carolee but what
should you do this is very often another
matter you see that okay I'm probably
all right but what exactly a month on a
word like am I playing yeah yeah maybe
it will just take f3m I don't want that
really 95 maybe but that's knight c6
that's really not great at all but what
else is there 96 m like a sound just
okay yo were just chatting chatting a
bit um rook c8 am of course he didn't
need to to play this some instantly 96
yeah it's tough here the direct this
direct attack is not leading to much I
go Quinn d3 there is even neither five
with them they're not sure
maybe rupee one I really don't have a
good idea here it shouldn't be so
terrible for white but it's not clear to
me how I'm going to play d4 d5 or get to
get an attack going it just seems very
reliable for Black Knight ed5 or 96 I
like 96 at the text deform and i'm not
sure if i have anything better than
trading and well I don't really want to
trade maybe after 96 white can just go
back to a3 and asking black if the night
is so well placed down maybe
hmm it's very slow okay I'm trying to
irritate him with rope 2 g-3 not sure
what the point was not be five I don't
know I don't really think that this was
a threat the only reason to play em a 6
really maybe he wants to play be five
but this is not helping in any way cam 2
g-3 there's not much threatened really
even night f5 as a move that Y term and
that's a black could have played okay
y'all rock g3 m93 i'm going to take with
the pawn and really hope for this king
cytotec I can't take with the rook on c1
done arguing that this might help me or
the tech just rocks III yeah oh why not
why not there are some some ideas in
this position if black plays for example
night to your form I can take it play
Queen g4 and win it and win the game
it's not totally easy but of course this
is an attacking position where i already
have traded a bit it's not
if really full force attack hmm that I'm
not sure about what about night chief
494 threatens night xf6 and night x h6
it looks like a problem Knight takes
Queen takes that's just made on g7 g6 I
can take that looks good actually maybe
he screwed this up with with the time
getting down time getting low the bad
thing is that also h6 hangs not just f6
but also h6 black can look planets
equity 7 i'm just going to take h6 enter
I'm perfectly all right I don't see him
actually clean maybe 26 was really a bad
mistake it seems like my remaining
attacking forces are fine oh I didn't
see that move at all Wow
okay it's not the end of the world
though I can play move like we seek to
wear or taking and then Kerwin screen d3
actually that's not threatening much can
easily escape from age 7 hmm
but enjoy what can I do here oh I take
windey 30 g6 stuff like age five but
it's you can just move the rook to see a
door something and then that's not clear
what I'm doing queen for added security
fence
hmm can I in somebody not take you know
what about night III 95 yeah it gives
age for just one problem of it okay Jack
it's not very convincing but I need to
play in this queen bee three you can
just play rook c8 unfortunately and h4
is hanging is it is attained really aged
for probably
yeah the problem is led by structures
not 100% healthy can easily attack the
c3 porn okay quite sure if this is
threatening anything I don't think so
but ya know h4 was also hanging and if
he goes rook c8 I mean at the moment see
three years covered it's not so easy to
increase the pressure them but it's not
clear or what I'm going to do
yeah we create just playing a simple
move what am i doing after that not sure
absolutely not sure I can play a slow
threat strengthening moves strong
whitening moves Bishop d3 a form this
type of stuff okay well maybe wants to
go up to five even yeah not bad
ok five Sherwood how much there is much
damage done maybe there's also a five
with the idea to play rook to d1 hmm
paso
I don't know really stuff tough to play
just trying to improve our background a
bit so that rook do you want is not a
constant very after you five or
something each form Luke v5 just in 3g
flow of course intending bishop reform
or even more born intending work f3
which would be quite nice
he can try worked with a after a five he
can try that ok now we'll get fries
obviously not working
yeah that's not good really not yeah I
don't really see move besides that
I'm fairly active here but I'm just down
a born and not cleared or how i can
continue here check each was protected
how to get counted flame now i don't
know maybe maybe queen 25s and with that
black is planning to play try to provoke
a weakness IAM 30 years on 30 seconds is
just far too slow
I need to move at least I mean just turn
black resins to em I was actually
thinking of offering it wrong but it's a
bit this is just bad for white I've been
just a pawn down but you need to play
some was at least to try to do you mean
increase the speed I mean I've I'm in
the situation often enough but at some
point you just need to try out the moves
and here i'm just a pawn down for
nothing basically it was really not a
position that promises much and maybe I
played it the the real problem here
actually was this move it looked
attractive and as I just I just
overlooked Queen f4 completely and this
is in fact a big problem if I don't do
that um I should be okay let's say Queen
d2 in taking here just attacking with
with pieces I should be in decent shape
or something like that for example it's
just a position to play with them with
the lambeth at least mutual mutual
chances computer likes white a lot
actually I'm not sure about it but this
is what I should do I simply I
completely really forgot about Queen FYI
we'll look at the move and this is a big
problem i cannot also not just go back i
mean there is this just hang Chang and
this is just not really good I mean I
played it badly of course but it was not
a really good position I should probably
other computer is is going for this why
not here actually hey yeah but this kind
of stuff is very tricky for human I
thought rook c8 just to be here
effective immediately losses due to
Bishop reform
very funny tactic this is easy jack but
this is the real deal check and also
wins material okay well let's see here
and then maybe Jack something and it was
something like that this is probably
better a better version of the game yeah
yeah the comp suggests this movie this
is of course better attacking a six and
probably leading to to an equal position
let's say like this and this is okay
probably yeah well yeah i'm just a pawn
down i have no way to protect the upon
this is some check yeah they overstep
the time yeah you just cover here let's
say let's say queen here one problem is
i cannot i cannot just get the porn back
because there's this one check this is
young downed and 21 yeah it's just it's
just very bad probably a probably lost
here with good technical play from the
black side but here somewhat freezer
froze here and just overstep the time um
yeah
maybe maybe i am i played this hormone
yeah a choice probably already not such
a brilliant idea maybe my black seems to
be okay I really am in this look at this
let's say I'd take it like I'll take on
g5 and this is simply not leading to
anything besides problems I mean mob not
really good yeah this are here 95 many
it's this so bad I can take is having a
tech g5 of course so I then ah then this
is what i should do really I should have
considered that that's bad this actually
I should have done and this should be
slightly better for wide ready with this
Bishop being the better piece compared
to the passive p7 Bishop and this was
probably a spot in the opening where I
lost them any here when I when I
actually decided to take this was the
point where lost or kind of all hope for
an advantage okay all good game but like
he just them didn't didn't speed up
really to to make it timewise alright
thanks for watching